[Music]
black holes really are kind of getting
to the very heart of our physics and I
believe that they're kind of showing us
the way that we're eventually we're
gonna need different physics and new
physics people ask questions like what
happens inside a black hole or even what
happens at the very boundaries of a
black hole the event horizon when light
is absorbed and honestly our physics is
telling us a lot of contradictory things
and our image of what an event horizon
really is maybe changing people like
like Stephen Hawking and Leonard
Susskind have recently come up with this
idea that a black hole should not be
able to destroy information okay what do
we mean by information information can
be almost anything you know all of the
different atoms in my body have angular
momentum they have charge they have mass
they they they they're that there's all
sorts of little bits of information that
make me me at the quantum mechanic level
you know did the tiniest of levels there
are different amounts of energy there
are different probabilities that are
contained in the structure of my matter
and information in some ways is a form
of energy it's actually you know a way
that you can describe something which is
somehow in a strange way a higher energy
state than not being able to describe
something and so one of the questions is
if energy really can't be destroyed
energy itself is something that is
intrinsic in the universe you can't
really create it or destroy it is it
possible that information is the same
way is there really no way to actually
destroy the information about what all
of my subatomic particles are doing
right now
so black hole is kind of steer you right
in the face well what a black hole
supposedly does it is it absorbs
everything space and time Bend into a
black hole so that nothing can escape
that means that any information about
the material that fell in is gone the
only thing we know about it is that as a
black hole absorbs material it gets more
massive it actually adds that mass to
the mass of the black hole and as that
mass increases the event horizon becomes
larger basically the area where
space is so curved that you can't get
out begins to extend the more mass of
the black hole is the most massive black
holes we know of in the universe are
many billions of times the mass of our
Sun and the physical extent of this
event horizon is about the size of our
solar system maybe like out to the
planet Pluto so is it possible then if
everything goes into a black hole and
nothing ever comes out space and time go
inside the black hole and don't come out
what happened to that information and
this has begun to make a lot of people
wonder if we really have thought of
black holes the wrong way maybe there
isn't an event horizon in the true sense
I actually had a friend of mine the
study's black holes say well I'm not
sure if they're black they may be very
very dark navy blue and and what he
meant by that is maybe there are some
tricks to actually get information out
of a black hole maybe there really is
some form of energy that can leak away
from the black hole over time now
Stephen Hawking wondered if quantum
effects very near the event horizon
could actually separate something called
virtual particles the the energy of
space itself if you're familiar with
Einstein's equation equals MC squared
energy equals mass times the speed of
light squared energy and mass are the
same thing they're equivalent
you can actually make mass into energy
and you can make energy into mass around
a black hole where there's very hot gas
very high temperatures very strong
magnetic fields perhaps there's a lot of
energy and that energy can actually
manifest itself as particles mass and
the energy always creates
particle/anti-particle pairs they're
called virtual particles and matter
antimatter the thing you know about it
is that it annihilates immediately so
these tiny little particles come into
existence that annihilates and you're
back to energy and this happens all
around us all the time
so if this happens near a black hole
it's possible one of these little
particles can go into the black hole and
the other one escapes and all of a
sudden is a particle that shouldn't be
there the universe basically has a new
particle energy from nowhere and how can
that work and the the information theory
people say the
what happens is that energy has to come
out of the black hole the black hole's
mass begins to decrease if there is this
poor little orphan particle that
shouldn't have been there in the first
place so over time tiny particle by tiny
particle these black holes can evaporate
away and maybe there's something about
those virtual particles that contain
some information about the black hole
and what fell into it it even gets
stranger than that because a lot of
people think that time goes slower and
slower as you approach a black hole till
at the event horizon time basically
stops so instead of anything really ever
falling into a black hole what the event
horizon may be is some sort of shell of
information things are stopped in time
as they fell into the black hole and
right at that boundary there's almost
kind of a sphere a two-dimensional
surface that somehow contains all the
information about what's inside the
black hole and this reminded people of
something that the humans invented
called a hologram now a hologram is a
two-dimensional object you can make out
a glass or a piece of film and you shine
a light through it and all of a sudden
there seem to be three-dimensional
projections and the idea is that are we
looking at some fundamental way the
universe stores information around a
black hole where space and time have
been crushed out of existence could
there be a shell of information
something like a hologram and a lot of
people began to wonder maybe that's the
way the universe works on a larger scale
maybe black holes are showing us
intrinsically what the underlying nature
of reality is that there really is a
two-dimensional surface of something
that contains all information about the
entire universe maybe in some way we are
part of this giant hologram and I should
mention that the word hologram in no way
implies that somebody made the hologram
we're just talking about the universe
may really be information contained in a
two-dimensional structure not the three
dimensions that were aware of now this
all sounds incredibly strange I'm always
a little bit afraid to even talk about
but I think that the thing to really
kind of gain from this
is that black holes are staring us right
in the face we're now observing them
they're right there and we cannot really
describe how the universe should work
with one of these things they don't make
sense the universe shouldn't be able to
lose information so how do you get
information when space itself are bent
in and nothing comes out black holes
maybe the key to where the next physics
has to go we all know that we need a
next Einstein a next quantum theory
something that actually describes how
gravity works in very intense situations
like a black hole now we're actually
observing black holes well enough that
we really have to get on this we really
have to figure out how the universe
works around one of these things and we
may end up learning what the universe
itself
really is
[Music]
you